non
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'atalaye
d'interdire que faire des nouvelles
dettes accumulées par la france depuis
le début de la crise du corps des virus
et de combien parle-t-on 200 250 300
milliards d'euros est ce que ce sera
davantage comment va-t-on les financer
et faudra-t-il les rembourser ou pas et
si on doit les rembourser comment
va-t-on faire qui va payer les réponses
à toutes ces questions divise
actuellement les économistes faut-il
avoir recours à la banque centrale
européenne ou pas faudra-t-il rembourser
la dette tourne pas mieux encore leur
réponse transcende les clivages auquel
ils nous ont habitués
alors pour y voir plus clair nous avons
quatre invités en se disant que si l'on
comprenait sur quoi ils ne sont pas
d'accord on comprendra peut-être où est
le problème
le premier c'est henri sterdyniak
membres des économistes atterrés vous
venez de publier crise économique 2020
avec stéphanie villiers aux éditions
economica wake est votre position henri
sterdyniak
dans le débat actuel qui divise les
économistes faut-il annuler pas annuler
comment financer et cetera
d'abord il faut remarquer que la france
n'a aucun problème pour financer son
déficit on on a pu emprunter 250
milliards à des taux nul voire négatif
la dette il faut continuer la dette
publique est une dette perpétuelle il
faut continuer à la faire tourner et
bien sûr il ya absolument pas question
d'annuler la dette alors qu'on peut sans
problème trouver des personnes qui
veulent bien la détenir et quant à
l'idée de faire annuler la dette que
détient la bce
c'est un projet y réfléchit nicolas
dufresne vous vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire directeur de l'institut
rousseau un think tank écologique fondé
cette année dont le président d'honneur
est gaël giraud et vous est le coauteur
avec alain grandjean d'une monnaie
écologique à un livre paru chez odile
jacob
en février dernier juste avant le
premier confinement alors vous votre
position vous êtes tous dans ce débat
alors bon soir alors oui moi je pense
que la dette détenue par la banque
centrale c'est à dire je le rappelle 485
milliards d'euros détenu aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire 20% de la dette publique
qui sont détenus par la banque centrale
il faut l'annuler parce que la banque
centrale a la possibilité de le faire et
parce qu'on ne va pas rembourser les 500
milliards d'euros de dette publique on a
accumulé depuis le début de l'année pour
lutter contre la crise du coc vide avec
des impôts ou avec des réductions de
dépenses publiques et je veux bien qu'on
fasse rouler la dette avec les taux
négatifs c'est tout à fait possible mais
c'est une solution qui a également
plusieurs limites
on y reviendra tout à l'heure j'imagine
nathalie jenson vous êtes économiste
professeur associé à la neoma business
school vous y situer où vous alors moi
je me situe dans le débat je suis
effectivement contre l'annulation de la
dette
voilà comme il a été dit pour le moment
la france n'a aucun problème pour faire
face à sa dette et ce serait regrettable
qu'elle annule au motif qu'on est qu'on
a eu à faire face à une pandémie donc un
événement exceptionnel pour des
questions de crédibilité et puis aussi
parce que le fait qu'on annule a aussi
des conséquences non seulement sur la
crédibilité mais le fait qu'on
introduise régulièrement des dettes et
des nouvelles dettes a des conséquences
sur ses décisions économiques qui flèche
l'allocation des ressources et donc ce
n'est pas neutre sur sur l'activité
économique
sergey nazis arrive vous vous êtes
délégué général de l'académie libre de
sciences humaines une plateforme
diffusant des savoirs aspiré par l'école
libérale votre position avoue elle se
situe ou alors moi je suis un peu plus
sceptiques sur la nécessité la moralité
de rembourser cette dette mais cette
position n'est pas lié à la crise du coc
vide je crois que c'est denis et à
celles liées à la nature même de la
dette publique
à mon sens il me paraît pas très juste
pas très moral d'imposer aux jeunes
générations
le remboursement d'une dette à laquelle
ils n'ont jamais souscrites et qui on
est et qui a été au contraire générés
par leurs aînés beaucoup moins on va
dire beaucoup plus laxiste entre
guillemets choux les finances publiques
donc je pense que la dette publique pose
un problème de moralité qu'à ce titre
elle doit pas être remboursés par des
jeunes générations quant aux
conséquences économiques ne seront
évidemment pas neutre il faudra y
revenir tout à l'heure pendant le débat
avant d'entrer dans le vif de ce débat
un moment sur ce qu'on a appelé la
région magique c'est président de la
république qui avait utilisé cette cette
métaphore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de français ont
l'impression que l'argent est devenu
magique puisqu'on peut non seulement en
emprunter des quantités phénoménales
mais des gens très sérieux des
économistes très sérieux peuvent même
nous dire qu'on pourrait éventuellement
ne pas les rembourser
alors est ce que l'argent magique ça
existe quand même après tout on pourrait
se dire l'argent c'est un contrat unique
contrat de confiance
on pourrait imaginer que tu en a tous
confiance dans la graine l'argent magic
eh bien ça marche henri sterdyniak un
polytechnicien comme vous qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent l'argent magique
vous savez que yann qu'elle se nous a
appris qu'il ya bien sûr de l'argent
magique qu'un chaque année il y a une
production et il y a une formation de
l'investissement mais les revenus de la
période ne suffisent pas acheter la
production et donc il faut naturellement
du crédit et l'argent magique en quelque
sorte c'est le crédit et le déficit
publics qui vont s'ajouter à la demande
provenant des revenus alors bien sûr ça
existe mais ça doit pas être trop
important il faut tenir compte des
contraintes de capacité de production ou
des contraintes de soldes extérieurs
mais en 2020 on est dans une situation
tout à fait particulière et donc dans
cette situation tout à fait particulière
effectivement l'état peut distribuer des
revenus importants
les gens ne les dépenses pas et donc on
est dans cette les gens les pagnes cette
épargne
viens aux banques les dépôts bancaires
sont replacés à la banque centrale est
donc on a un circuit qui peut donner
l'impression qu'effectivement il ya de
l'argent magique
on verra l'année prochaine ou dans deux
ans si cet argent effectivement dépensé
nicolas dufresne
oui alors déjà je constate avec plaisir
que finalement monsieur sterdyniak pense
qu'il y a de l'argent magique j'ai le
souvenir de l'avoir lu plusieurs fois
écrire le contraire mais bon passons
effectivement l'argent est magique par
nature c'est d'ailleurs dans le livre
que vous avez rappelé en introduction de
l'émission qu'on a écrit avec mon ami
alain grandjean nous vous ouvrons sur
cette séquence d'emmanuel macro ont chu
de rouen qui dit il n'y a pas d'argent
magique
et bien si l'argent est magique par
nature et il n'y a que de l'argent
magique puisque l'argent est une
institution sociale qui fonctionne selon
la confiance que lui accorde une société
et bien sûr aujourd'hui où le lien de la
monnaie avec les métaux précieux est
définitivement rompu et définitivement
coupé depuis 1971 et depuis notamment la
décision du président nixon de couper le
lien du dollar et de l'or il n'ya encore
plus que de l'argent magique puisqu'il
n'ya même plus de lien avec les métaux
précieux et si on enlevait une
illustration tout à fait saisissante on
peut rappeler que depuis le mois de mars
de cette année la banque centrale
européenne a créé pas loin de 1800
milliards d'euros de liquidités pour
calmer le système financier face aux
difficultés qu'on a les connaît la
question n'est donc pas de savoir s'il y
a de l'argent magique bien sûr qu'il y
en a la question est de savoir ce qu'on
en fait et pour qui on le crès voilà la
vraie question d'intelligence on argent
magic ou pas alors non pas d'argent
magique chez moi il n'y a pas d'agent
magique parce que c'est ça vient en
effet dû sans doute delà de la création
monétaire
via les banques qui peuvent donner
l'impression qu'il ya une création
recueil de l'argent magique puisque en
effet on va pouvoir accorder des crédits
sur la base de dépôts donc en fait voilà
pour faire simple ce n'est pas comme
lorsqu'on achète une action et qu'on va
donner son épargne à une entreprise
voilà pour qu'elle puisse investir dans
le cas des banques en fait par le jeu
d'écriture on va pouvoir prêter d'argent
et deuxièmement pour répondre à monsieur
dufresne en fait pour ce qui est de la
création de la bce
elle n'a pas à cri de l'argent
magiquement elle a simplement échanger
des titres pour de la liquidité
donc elle les a rendu plus liquide il
n'y a pas d'agent magique ferghana ziare
non il n'y a pas non plus d'argent
magique de mon point de vue une idée de
l'argent magique laisse entendre que
toute cette création monétaire cet
endettement quasi gratuit pour les états
se fait sans contrepartie ils moi
j'aimerais quand même rappeler que
depuis que les banques centrales et a
fortiori la banque centrale européenne
fait preuve de laxisme
ça gronde un petit peu chez nos voisins
du nord ça gronde en allemagne celle
qu'on aux pays bas ça gronde chez les
pays nordiques ça gronde chez ceux qui
pensent que les pays du sud sont en
train de spolier les épargnants des pays
du nord donc y avait toujours une
contrepartie au laxisme monétaire
aujourd'hui en vidéo sont sans sens que
la magie n'existe jamais en économie et
l'autre conséquences négatives
éventuelles 7
en effet la l'altération de la qualité
de la monnaie et le risque
inflationniste qui est certes
aujourd'hui ne se manifeste pas avec les
biens de consommation courants mais on
observe une inflation du prix des actifs
dans plusieurs pays et certains
spécialistes pensent que ces corps et
les eaux au laxisme monétaire de la bce
monsieur dufresne tout à leur rappelait
que effectivement nous vivions dans un
monde
deux monnaies fiat déconnecté des métaux
précieux mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
faille s'en féliciter puisque quand vous
prenez aujourd'hui par exemple
l'émergence des cryptes monnaie eh bien
c'était ma chance elle est liée à une
défiance envers un système monétaire et
financier qui pour beaucoup est devenu
complètement vicié du fait que les
banquiers centraux se plaisent à créer
de la fausse monnaie sans contrepartie
avec le risque de perte de confiance
dans les monnaies officielle et donc la
l'éventualité que les agents économiques
se mettent à court moyen ou long terme à
se tourner vers des actifs qu'ils jugent
plus fiables alors justement parlons de
la banque centrale européenne est ce que
est ce qu'il faut compter sur la bce qui
a racheté je crois de 1200 milliards de
dettes publiques européennes depuis le
début de la crise henri sterdyniak
le rôle de la banque centrale européenne
pour vous dans cette affaire qu'elle
doit-il être et bien la bce a comme vous
savez de nombreux rôles yann ses rôles
c'est bien sûr de garantir la valeur de
la monnaie et de la la la bce garantit
que l'inflation n'est pas trop forte et
jusqu'à présent elle a réussi donc il
n'y a pas à craindre l'inflation
contrairement à ce qu'a dit
l'intervenant précédent la bce contrôler
les banques et la bce doit intervenir
pour faciliter la les miller le
financement des déficits publics
et c'est ce qu'elle fait magnifiquement
puisqu'en 2000 va effectivement les pays
européens ont pu et ont pu sans problème
financer les déficits qui a été rendue
nécessaire par la crise
c'est parfait il faut bien voir que en
faisant cela la bce a accumulé
effectivement des titres publics mais en
contrepartie elle a aussi accumulé des
dépôts que les banques ont fait auprès
d'elle et donc la bce est un
intermédiaire financier et détient des
titres publics mais en contrepartie
naturellement dans son bilan
il y a des dépôts bancaires et donc en
aucun cas nos quinquas la bce pourrait
annuler les titres qu'elle détient
parce qu'à ce moment là la bce serait
aurait un bilan déficitaire qu'il aurait
des problèmes si les taux d'intérêt
remontent est et que en fait ça
signifierait que la bce devient porteuse
de la dette du déficit public
ce qui bien sûr n'est en aucun cas son
rôle et qu'il se fait dans aucun pays du
monde
nathalie 1 jenson sur le rôle de la bce
vous êtes dubitative 1 j'ai l'impression
que vous vous associez sa du populisme
monétaire si je vous ai bien
lui disons que pour la bce est
effectivement la banque centrale
historiquement parlant a plutôt eu un
rôle vis-à-vis des banques en fait voilà
c'était la banque centrale avait et
quand elle est l'aînée à différentes
époques voilà donc dans les pays
européens il pour finir sur le continent
américain et la plupart du temps elles
venaient gérer des problèmes de
liquidité entre les banques
en fait cette espèce de banques
supérieur et elle a toujours eu quand
même une connotation financement du de
l'état mais de façon c'était plutôt
liées aux guerres alors la bombe dans le
cas de la france et s était plus
explicite puisque comme napoléon a créé
la banque de france c'est clair qu'il
avait comme objectif d'aider au
financement des gars il ya toujours août
et cette ambiguïté de la banque centrale
dans son rôle vis-à-vis de l'état même
si son rôle premier était quand même
voilà avant tout de faciliter la le le
fonctionnement du système bancaire pour
avoir une liquidité assurée sa liquidité
et faire en sorte que le système
bancaire soit stable et là le lien avec
le financement d'état eh bien il à eelv
à dire qu'il est allé venu au gré des
des idées des situations de la dette des
différents hectares donc c'est pas par
hasard qu'en fait on a à nous cette
problématique et qu'on dit non on
discute aujourd'hui la monétisation de
la dette parce que depuis la crise de
on a eu un retour des dettes publiques
et donc on a on a eu nos comment on peut
dire que si on peut dire une une
fiscalisation de la politique monétaire
sert qu'en fait la politique monétaire a
commencé à jouer un rôle fiscal ce qui a
priori n'est pas son rôle naturel
nicolas dufrasne oui alors moi j'ai
plusieurs points si vous me permettez
déjà un bref retour sur l'argent magique
je voudrais quand même rappeler des
choses tout à fait précise et concrète
aujourd'hui toutes les banques centrales
admettent que ce sont les crédits qui
font les dépôts c'est contraire
être au sens commun c'est à dire on a
tendance à penser que les banques
prêtent les les dépose quel on encaisse
et bien non c'est les banques qui créent
de la monnaie au moment où elles
accordent des crédits ou au moment où
elles s'achètent des actifs financiers à
des agents non bancaire donc ça c'est
une première chose et c'est pour ça
qu'on dit que la création monétaire est
une opération ex nihilo
c'est du latin qui signifie à partir de
rien c'est donc bien que cette création
monétaire fait apparaître quelque chose
là où avant il n'y avait rien et ça
c'est quand même très important de le
rappeler
quand on dit que la bce
madame disait la bce échange des
liquidités contre des titres
oui très bien mais d'où viennent ces
liquidités
elle écrit c'est évident il ne peut pas
en être autrement
donc c'est bien qu'il y à de la création
monétaire
alors maintenant sur le rôle de la
banque centrale européenne alors déjà
elle a joué un rôle important pour
effectivement à travers ses achats
d'actifs réduire le taux d'intérêt sur
les emprunts publics
elle l'a très bien joué ce rôle
aujourd'hui les taux sont son nul voire
négatif la france emprunte à des taux
négatifs jusqu'à des périodes de 12 ans
jusqu'à des échéances de 12 ans qu'il
considère à beaucoup de pays européens
sont son pareil maintenant est-ce
qu'elle pourrait aller plus loin oui
évidemment nous ce qu'on propose c'est
d'annuler les dettes publiques qui sont
bilan de la banque centrale c'est-à-dire
ses 2400 milliards d'euros que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure et c'est un
chiffre qui est en progression constante
parce que la banque centrale rachète de
plus en plus de dette publique sur les
marchés
et notre proposition c'est que la banque
centrale passe un contrat avec les états
en dix ans nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une situation économique très difficile
nous possédons une quantité importante
de vos dettes
nous acceptons de l'annuler mais en
échange vous investissez massivement
pour sauver la situation économique et
pour relancer l'économie qui en a bien
besoin
c'est donc pour ça que la bce peut jouer
un rôle considérable dans la relance
économique
alors j'en termine par la henri
sterdyniak nous dit oui mais la bce si
elle fait ça elle aura un d un bilan
déséquilibré
j'ai envie de dire très bien et alors
qu'elle est qu'elle est la conséquence
de ça est ce qu'une banque centrale peut
faire faillite
bien sûr que non c'est même christine
lagarde elle-même qui l'a reconnu et qui
a dit récemment qu'une banque centrale
ne pouvait jamais être à court de
monnaie ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut souligner donc la
question et j'y reviens c'est toujours
de savoir comment on utilise ce pouvoir
de création monétaire au profit de la
société et au profit de la relance
écologique voilà et henri sterdyniak il
faut comprendre ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que la dette publique elle même
n'a aucune limite
donc il ya aucune différence
1 l'état le pas quand la vérité je te
crées de l'un peut l'état quand il veut
peut avoir un déficit public
les banques automatiquement rachète ses
titres parce qu'ils ont la garantie que
la bce va effectivement les refinancer
et la proposition un peu saugrenue que
nous venons d'entendre consiste à dire
cette dette publique de l'état
on va décider à part on va décider que
ça va devenir une dette publique de la
bce
or si on fait ça on peut faire ça d'un
trait de plus ça ne modifie en rien aux
rien les revenus ou le patrimoine
d'aucuns agents autre que la bce et
l'état sachant par ailleurs que la bce
est la propriété des états membres de
façon générale est donc cette mesure
n'aurait strictement strictement aucune
conséquence c'est un s'est vraiment
donné un coup de couteau dans l'eau
alors naturellement personne ne sera
dupe
parce que étant donné que la bce
appartient aux états la dette de la bce
naturellement
aurait automatiquement à des parties
entre les états donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la comptabilité créatif ce
que ce café dronne où n'importe quand
n'importe quelle entreprise qui frotte
ça consiste à masquer sa dette en disant
je vais le l'attribué à une filiale à
une succursale
il faut rappeler que la bce lorsqu'elle
a des profits les retransmet à il
fallait les donne automatiquement aux
pays membres n'a aucune lalabé sien est
en quelque sorte une émanation des pays
membres et site du jour au lendemain on
disait les 2400 milliards de de la bce
c'est maintenant une dette de la bce
plutôt qu'une dette d aides d etat ça ne
changerait strictement rien il faut dire
clairement que la proposition que nous
venons d'entendre si elle était sérieuse
naturellement les états unis le japon la
grande-bretagne l'aurait mis en
application
donc c'est quelque personne qui en
france croit avoir trouvé une méthode
magique pour 10 packs pour faire
disparaître la la dette publique
personne personne ne peut les prendre au
sérieux
voilà c'est comme ça on reviendra sur la
question de l'annuler ou pas la dette
dans les deux parties de réduction mais
je voulais entendre ferghana ziari sur
sur le rôle de la bce est ce qu'elle a
est-ce qu'elle a le bon rôle pour vous
mais je trouve que monsieur tard dîner
qui a été très précis sur le rôle
aujourd'hui de la bce qui consiste
effectivement à aider les états restent
dans une situation de laxisme budgétaire
et c'est en ce sens que la bce est
aujourd'hui une espèce de pousse au
crime qui d un site complètement les
états à faire preuve de rigueur dans la
gestion de leurs finances publiques avec
des conséquences fâcheuses que ça sur
l'économie puisque l'état se permettant
aujourd'hui effectivement d'être
irresponsable sur le plan budgétaire
gras
ça la caution de la bce n'a plus aucune
incitation à réduire ses dépenses
publiques à assainir ses finances
publiques et donc à permettre au secteur
privé de se réapproprier les capitaux
que les gouvernements détournent
aujourd'hui par leur décision le fait
que la bce les banques centrales à
parviennent à manipuler tout intérêt
alors beaucoup semblent s'en féliciter
sur ce plateau mais je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure ça pose aussi un problème un
moment de rémunération de l'épargné ça
pose aussi un problème d'affectation des
capitaux puisque le risque d'avoir une
des taux d'intérêts complètement déréglé
cdh aussi de de dérégler l'allocation
des capitaux de favoriser une espèce de
zombification de l'économie ou des
capitaux finalement vont irriguer des
entreprises ce qui n'aurait jamais dû
être irrité parce qu'elles ne sont pas
suffisamment productif parce qu'elles ne
produisent pas grand chose donc en ce
sens j'ai l'impression que cette
politique monétaire que tout le monde
vante aujourd'hui nous dirigent vers une
espèce de stagnation de l'économie
européenne
parce que elle a franchi les états et
les acteurs privés dont vous tapez
mesure d'une certaine discipline
et alors le coût de cette de ce laxisme
ne choque personne parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus il est assez diffus dans
l'espace et dans le temps c'est à dire
que personne ne va sanctionner le
personnel politique parce que le pays
aura connu deux 3 points de croissance
en dessous du taux qu'on aurait connu si
l'économie avait été assainie mais je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit un procédé
simple pour autant mais vagues en
algérie pour qu'on comprenne bien pour
vous le l'état ne devrait pas aider des
entreprises que par ailleurs il a soit
administrativement fermées pour cause de
qu'ovide du fait du confinement ou tout
simplement parce qu'elles souffrent de
l'arrêt de l'activité économique qui
encore une fois était décidée par l'état
pas parce que les entreprises étaient
par bonne santé vous avez juste une
minute avait de répondre vous avez tout
à fait raison mais l'enjeu c'est de
redonner aux entreprises la liberté
et de redémarrer l'activité économique
mais il faut bien comprendre aujourd'hui
que lorsque l'état aide quelqu'un c'est
toujours au détriment de quelqu'un
d'autre l'état n'a pas d'autres
richesses que celle qu'ils prélèvent
aujourd'hui aux secteurs productifs ou
bien marchés financiers donc quand
l'état a dit paul des avis forcément
pierre donc je pense que au delà de 2 de
la soviétisation de l'économie à
laquelle aujourd'hui on assiste l'enjeu
c'est de retrouver de redonner le plus
vite possible la liberté au secteur
productif aux travailleurs aux
entreprises de subvenir à nouveau à
leurs besoins en sachant pertinemment
que l'état encore une fois n'a pas
d'argent magique et que l'argent qu'ils
donnent à des entreprises il va
nécessairement le prélever à quelqu'un
d'autre c'est mathématique
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après pour continuer le débat
[Musique]
c'est un élément essentiel au bon
fonctionnement de notre économie
l'investissement étranger si on arrive à
être aussi attractif c'est bien qu'on
donne des compensations aux entreprises
étrangères pour venir on n'attire pas
les mouches à miel qu'est ce que c'est
que la tyrrell attirer c'est lui donner
des franchises d'un gros lui donner un
certain nombre de garanties en après
toutes les enquêtes qualitatives qu'on
fait c'est pas tellement la fiscalité
qui fait le petit plus c'est le petit
cerise sur le gâteau de certains c'est
essentiellement les services publics la
main d'oeuvre qualifiée
le fait que la france est au centre de
l'union européenne qui est une énorme
zone est ce que la crise a dû
coronavirus est en train de remettre
tous les compteurs à zéro
c'est en train de remettre tous les
compteurs à zéro et particulièrement en
france je ne suis pas sûr que la mariée
soit si belle que ça
à la sortie du colis
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que s'il est une histoire de vie
et de mort
il faut protéger la végétation pour
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas que tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise je suis poli
[Musique]
nous reprenons ce débat sur les dettes
accumulées depuis le début de la crise
vu que vide par un pays comme la france
débat qui a lieu avec henri sterdyniak
avec nicolette dufresne nathalie jenson
et fergane ziari henri sterdyniak vous
parlais au début de cette émission de 2
de dette perpétuelle qu'est ce qu'on
entend par faire des dettes perpétuelles
s'est laissé traîner ses sa a faire des
dettes perpétuelles ça signifie que
l'état
année après année rembourse
naturellement la dette qui arrivait à
échéance
mais automatiquement quasiment
automatiquement
il serait en dette donc il fait tourner
sa dette et en plus naturellement il a
une aide si nécessaire
correspondant à son nouveau déficit et
tout ça s'accumule sans problème tant
que effectivement il n'ya pas des
déséquilibres qui ferait que la dette
publique ou les déficits provoque des
taux d'intérêt ou des taux d'inflation
excessif alors c'est absolument pas la
situation en 2020 est tout à fait
absurde de dire qu'en 2020 effectivement
les sommes que l'état verse aux
entreprises ou aux ménages ils les
prélève sur d'autres agents comme l'a si
bien dit nicolas dufresne le l'état
comme les banques craie du pouvoir
d'achat le problème c'est qu'il faut
créer suffisamment de pouvoir d'achat
mais pas trop déconner dufresne
oui alors déjà je voudrais rappeler que
des abandons de créances en fait on voit
ça tous les jours les banques pratiquent
ça tous les jours c'est à dire de
l'annulation des dettes quand il ya une
situation difficile pour un emprunteur
c'est une solution financière
tout à fait courante qu'on met
en oeuvre régulièrement ensuite pour
rebondir sur ce que disait tout à
l'heure monsieur sterdyniak en nous
disant finalement ça ne changerait rien
annuler des têtes ça me changerait rien
je voudrais rappeler que notre
proposition c'est d'annuler la partie
des dettes publiques détient la bce en
échange d'investissements de même
montant si bien que comme la banque
centrale par exemple possède pour la
france 485 milliards d'euros la
conditionnalité ce serait très investir
le même montant et vous imaginez
qu'aujourd'hui où on a des plans de
relance qui sont extrêmement faibles et
pas du tout à la hauteur des enjeux
ça ferait du bien d'avoir des cinq
pareil qui pourraient être débloqués et
servir la la la la relance économique et
donc bien sûr ça changerait radicalement
le niveau des revenus des agents
économiques parce que ça permettrait
d'injecter du carburant dans la machine
je rappelle aussi monsieur sterdyniak
nous disait que le bilan de la banque
centrale et celui de l'état finalement
c'est à peu près la même chose et bien
non c'est complètement faux puisque
quand l'état rembourse les dettes à la
banque centrale que la banque centrale a
préalablement achetés et bien il y doit
trouver la môme est ailleurs alors
effectivement soit il peut ré emprunter
pour rembourser ses dettes c'est ce
qu'il fait régulièrement ce qu'on
appelle faire rouler sa dette
mais imaginons que l'état veuille
réduire sa dette et bien dans ce cas là
ça veut dire qu'ils empruntent moins
pour rembourser et que pour compenser la
différence
il prélève des impôts ou bien il réduit
des dépenses publiques c'est ce qu'on
appelle une politique d'austérité
et je rappelle que le pacte de stabilité
et de croissance qui est absurde je
pense que sur ce point on sera tout à
fait d'accord avec monsieur sterdyniak
n'en continue pas moins d'être une
réalité même si aujourd'hui les
suspendus pendant la crise et ça
continue d'être une réalité et ce pacte
de stabilité et de croissance européen
qui nous empêche de dépasser
théoriquement 60% de dette publique
contraint les états à diminuer leur
endettement à diminuer leurs déficits et
donc à conduire des politiques
d'austérité est le meilleur exemple de
ceux ci c'est que pendant la décennie
2010 2020 alors même que grâce à la
politique de la banque centrale
les états européens pourraient
s'endetter à taux nul ou à taux négatifs
eh bien figurez vous que les états
européens ce sont en moyenne désendetter
c'est à dire qu'ils en faire reculer
leur dette publique alors même qu'il y
avait tant pas fait tant à faire pour
investir pour investir dans une
politique de reconstruction écologique
pour investir dans le social pour
investir dans les hôpitaux dans les
services publics dans les
infrastructures et dans tous les
investissements dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui qui sont considérables pour
réussir les défis auxquels on est
confrontés donc donc l'annulation est
une solution tout à fait souhaitable
je ne sais pas la seule il pourrait y
avoir on pourrait aussi imaginer la
monétisation sans contrepartie des
dépenses publiques c'est à dire que la
banque centrale crée de la monnaie libre
c'est à dire libre d'endettement pour
financer des grands investissements sous
le contrôle du parlement et des
gouvernements et je signale d'ailleurs
que les propres collègues de monsieur
sterdyniak halo fce ont fait cette
proposition dans un article très récent
oui il proposait de monétiser les dettes
publiques comme nous nous l'avons fait
dans notre livre avec alain grandjean et
comme d'autres économistes l'ont fait
également à la question quand on parle
de rembourser les dettes
je vous donne la parole tout de suite en
restant lignac on vous entend pas là
c'est vous le vous le dites il faut
rembourser dans ces cas là qui va payer
et quand henry skyrock
henri sterdyniak vous m'entendez
oui oui la monnaie libre la mode lan
monnet libre sans endettement associés
ça n'existe pas lorsqu'au fait du crédit
naturellement naturally nantes
d'un côté on donne de l'argent à des à
des emprunteurs et de l'autre
naturellement on crée une dette donc ce
que monsieur nicolas dufresne nous
raconte n'a strictement aucun sens et
par ailleurs par ailleurs l'annulation
de la dette ça signifiera effectivement
de dire à des gens qui ont prêté à la
france désolé
dorénavant on vous remboursera pas la
dette là ceux ci ont dis simplement on
annule la partie de la dette qui est
détenue par la banque centrale
on annule rien du tout tout simplement
parce que la banque centrale reste très
endetté vis-à-vis des banques
commerciales et que ces banques
commerciales continuerait être endetté
vis-à-vis de leurs clients
donc c'est une opération purement fictif
est par ailleurs par ailleurs bien sûr
qu'il faut des politiques de relance
bien sûr qu'il faut des politiques pour
la transition écologique mais ça
strictement rien à voir avec cette idée
complètement magique qui on pourrait
faire disparaître les dettes publiques
tout simplement en les transférant de
l'état à la boxe entre haddock
je dis tout simplement à monsieur du
fred et à l'institut rousseau et à gaël
giraud revenez à la raison
revenez à une société anne position
simple oui il faut financer la
transition écologique on a besoin
d'argent qui est tout à fait
naturellement on peut le financer par le
crédit comme on a toujours fait comme on
a financé les hlm et comme on a financé
la reconstruction part du crédit
bancaire
dragana diaries vous aussi vous êtes
pour l'annulation de la dette alors
qu'ici c'était le cas dans votre dans
votre schéma avouent qu'ils paieraient
je trouve que monsieur star lignac est
très honnête sur les conséquences
éventuelle annulation comme moi j'ai
j'assume contrairement à monsieur
dufresne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si
il fallait annuler la dette publique
pas nécessairement ce qui serait
désespérant les créanciers de l'état
donc il ya toujours quelqu'un qui paye
donc ses créances et aujourd'hui ce sont
les épargnants ce sont ceux qui ont de
l'assurance vie ce sont aussi les
épargnants étrangers depuis ce une
grande partie de la dette française est
détenue par des étrangers
donc la question est de savoir qui paie
en fait je crois qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de scénarios ou bien on finance
on rembourse sa dette par l'impôt et
donc ce sont les travailleurs qui vont
rembourser cette dette sur x années et
on revient sur la question de moralité
que j'ai énoncé plutôt parce que le
grand souci quand même de rembourser la
dette publique par l'impôt c'est que on
impose une dette à des gens qui n'ont
jamais souscrit à cette date qu'est ce
qui fait la légitimité d'une dette sur
le plan sur le plan moral et
philosophique c'est simplement que elle
est le fruit d'un accord volontaire
or par définition la dette publique n'a
absolument rien de volontaire puisque on
l'a expliqué tout à l'heure ce sont les
vieilles générations entre guillemets
qui vont imposer aux générations à
naître celles qui n'ont pas encore le
droit de vote des impôts supplémentaires
pour rembourser la dette publique donc à
la question de savoir qui va payer
il faut choisir entre deux maux ou bien
on considère que sous les travailleurs
actuels qui paie mine en ce cas là ça me
parait fondamentalement injuste ou bien
on considère que ce sont les créanciers
de l'état vêtu doivent payer ça me
paraît être le moindre mal à se
soustraire que moi je suis un tout petit
peu moins démago entrée 10 mai que
monsieur dufresne c'est que j'assume tue
aura des conséquences négatives à savoir
que le risque d'un défaut de paiement
des états c'est un déficit de
crédibilité auprès des créanciers mais
moi en tant que libéral sous licence à
me gêne pas trop que l'état perdre en
crédibilité parce que au moins les
capitaux irait désormais au secteur
privé l économie productive
n'irai plus renflouées des
administrations improductives et c'est
en ce sens que je suis je suis tout à
fait à l'aise avec ce scénario la
dentelle jenson vous êtes pour que la
dette soit remboursée normalement dans
ce cas là qui doit payer
mais il ya différentes possibilités
lorsqu'on a une dette
bon évidemment la dette de l'état et
selon son niveau bien évidemment elle
est remboursée par les par les recettes
fiscales est en fait ces recettes
fiscales dépendent de deux choses taux
d'imposition
et puis la base qu'elle sur laquelle
elle s'impose donc on n'est pas
forcément obligé de voir le
remboursement comme étant nécessairement
une hausse de la fiscalité même si
souvent c'est ce à quoi on aboutit en
fait naturellement mais on peut voir
aussi on pourrait éventuellement faire
en sorte qu'une allergie cement de la
base des revenus tirés de l'activité
c'est à dire libéré l'activité
économique pour que à taux d'imposition
égale elle puisse se produire plus de
recettes fiscales
d'un autre côté comme on l'a noté aussi
voilà il a été évoqué les politiques
d'austérité qu'on voit là qu'on appelle
d'austérité bonsu chez nous on a quand
même pas faire on a fait de l'austérité
entre guillemets vraiment papa papa pas
au sens strict du terme puisque de toute
façon on a on a été le pays en europe
qui a le moins réduit son sa dette et
son déficit est de toute façon on a
surtout agi sur l'augmentation des
recettes est pas tout pas du tout sur
une diminution des dépenses et puis en
général ça va avec un large large
révision en fait des dépenses publiques
puisque comme il a été aussi dit par
monsieur sterdyniak effectivement de
l'état lorsqu'il alou sont ses finances
il va allouer à différents secteurs donc
lorsqu'il décide d'orienter plus vers un
secteur que d'un autre il fait des choix
et lorsqu'on
on a une enveloppe aussi budgétaire et
bien on fait aussi des choix
donc c'est tout on doit repenser
effectivement la dépense publique et
c'est un débat qui qu'en france on n'a
jamais absolument jamais ouvert et c'est
bien dommage parce qu'effectivement si
la dette augmente pour le moment
effectivement elle et la soutenabilité
de la dette dépend essentiellement d'un
rapport entre taux d'intérêt taux de
croissance aujourd'hui la faiblesse des
taux d'intérêt c'est vrai qu'elle est
elle peut évoquer comme étant un
scénario-catastrophe possible
aujourd'hui
et puis ça dépend toujours des
possibilités de recettes fiscales
futures et c'est pour ça que des pays
qui sont beaucoup plus endettés ont pu
très bien continuer sans avoir sans être
inquiétés par des problèmes de défauts
de paiement à ce titre on comparera
effectivement des pays comme le japon
ça fait très longtemps qu'ils ont des
dettes publiques au sud de 100%
ça n'empêche qu'ils n'ont pas fait
défaut même avant que la banque centrale
ne possède massivement leurs dettes et
au regard de sa si on voit la grèce qui
l a fait défaut elle avait une dette qui
n'était pas aussi élevée que celle du
japon donc l'histoire d'endettement et
le niveau d'endettement c'est toujours
par rapport à la possibilité en fait de
remboursement et c'est là où rentrent en
jeu la question des recettes fiscales et
de la possibilité de voir ses recettes
fiscales augmentent et donc bien
évidemment si on pense qu'il ya un
rebond d'activité économique fort qui
sera après le coded un peu comme des
situations si vous voulez ma vie n'a
rien à voir mais de guerre quoi on
s'endette beaucoup mais comme on sait
qu'on va après tout reconstruire on va
avoir une forte augmentation de la
croissance forte augmentation de la
productivité
mais finalement le fort endettement
n'est pas si problématique que ça
puisque après on a un retour des
recettes fiscales
il ya énormément de restaurants de bars
qui ont dû emprunter d'ailleurs leurs
emprunts sont garanties par l'état
il était déjà endetté avant parce qu'il
avait fait des investissements
aujourd'hui le sont encore plus à cause
du coc vide ils ne peuvent pas à
travailler puisque leur restaurant leurs
bars sont fermés mais qui peut imaginer
qu'une fois qu'on va les laisser ouvrir
ils vont augmenter tout à coup comme par
miracle de 25% le rectangle leur
rentabilité leur chiffre d'affaires pour
pouvoir rembourser leurs dettes c'est
absurde jamais quand vous avez un
restaurant vous ne pourrez pas comme ça
par un coup de baguette magique décidé
que la rentabilité
la croissance va augmenter de 25% c'est
inimaginable
donc on peut imaginer aujourd'hui
certains il faut que la tiens d'entre
eux va être obligé de mettre la clé sous
la porte
mais je m'avance un peu on en reparlera
je vous ai posé la question à à nicolas
dufresne vous dans votre essai dario
avouent qu'ils payent alors qu'ils
paient injustement le seul acteur qui
peut payer en ces circonstances c'est à
dire l'état est derrière la banque
centrale vous évoquez à très juste titre
les dettes privées qu'est ce qui va se
passer avec les prêts garantis pour
l'état qu'on a aujourd'hui une grande
partie ne sont tout simplement pas pas
remboursé il y aura des annulations de
dettes pour le secteur privé et il
faudrait que il y ait des annulations de
dettes aussi pour l'état qui lui même
s'est endetté pour le secteur privé par
le seul acteur qui peut le faire c'est à
dire la banque centrale alors je
voudrais quand même souligner quelque
chose qui me frappe depuis le début du
débat c'est que finalement monsieur
sterdyniak et monsieur asie harry et son
est tout à fait d'accord finalement sur
les constats et sur les solutions donc
voyez qu'il y a l'alliance entre une
certaine soi-disant économistes atterrés
et une branche ou ultra libérale de
l'économie
une alliance autour du thème il faudra
payer et la banque centrale ne peut pas
payer
donc il faudra prélever des impôts donc
il n'ya pas de mona libre par exemple
quand monsieur sterdyniak nous dit la
monnaie l'ip ça n'existe pas c'est une
invention
je voudrais simplement lui rappeler que
non seulement ça a déjà existé dans
l'histoire c'est ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne dans l'est
années 30 c'est ce qu'a fait la france
au moment de la reconstruction avec des
avances non remboursable de la banque
centrale par rapport à l'état c'est ce
que fait la chine aujourd'hui c'est ce
que fossiles et les états unis
donc ça n'a aucun sens ce que dit
monsieur sterdyniak la monnaie libre
existe elle est pratiquée par des états
pendant que nous ne faisons rien parce
que nous restons sur des vieilles idées
économiques défense monsieur sterdyniak
ne correspond plus du tout à la réalité
et c'est d'ailleurs d'autant plus
marquant que les propres collègues de
monsieur sterdyniak dans son laboratoire
de recherche le lot fce qui est un
laboratoire d'économie bien connu on
écrit la phrase suivante que j'ai sous
les yeux
ces propositions de monétisation
s'apparente à un financement monétaire
des dépenses publiques leur avantage
tient au fait qu'elles soutiennent
directement les dépenses et qu'elles
n'ont pas pour contrepartie une dette
exigible
c'est donc bien les propres collègues de
monsieur sterdyniak qui sont finalement
en faveur de la monétisation comme
évidemment bien d'autres les économistes
très sérieux comme adair turner comme
gaël giraud comme jézabel couppey
soubeyran laurentia l'homme enfin bref
la halle
la liste est longue donc effectivement
c'est bien la banque centrale qui
pourrait payer qui pourrait assumer ses
dettes
senard cela n'a rien d'une opération
magique où c'est tout simplement
l'application de mécanismes comptables
de la possibilité qu'a la banque
centrale de créer de la monnaie et donc
de la mettre au service de la
collectivité et voilà parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez quatre
scénarios si vous voulez si je peux
prendre juste deux minutes pour pour
expliquer ça vous avez quatre scénarios
pour pour faire face elle avec nicolas
d'accord alors je vais essayer de les
résumer très rapidement vous avez le
premier scénario c'est l'austérité la
baisse des dépenses publiques
c'est une catastrophe on a vu ce que ça
donnait en grèce
aujourd'hui la grèce est un pays très
appauvri est encore plus endettée qu'au
départ de la crise grecque
donc ça c'est une très mauvaise solution
vous avez un deuxième scénario qui est
le cantonnement sais ce que c'est ce à
quoi réfléchir le gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que vous prenez
la dette issue du coc vide vous la
mettez dans une structure particulière
et puis vous lever un nouvel impôt pour
payer la dette publique donc là en
l'occurrence comme on a 500 milliards
d'euros d'augmentation dette
ça voudrait dire qu'il faudrait
consacrer pendant sept ans l'équivalent
de l'impôt sur le revenu parce que
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est 70 milliards
d'euros uniquement remboursement de la
dette de cette dette cantonné c'est tape
sur il ya une troisième solution c'est
ce que propose monsieur sterdyniak c'est
de dire il faut laisser filer la dette
c'est pas un problème l'état s'endette à
taux négatifs ya pas de problème moi je
suis pas en désaccord avec cette idée là
mais à plusieurs limites
la première limite c'est qu'est ce qui
se passe si les taux d'intérêts demain
remonte et bien à ce moment-là il ça
sera un effet catastrophique sur les
finances publiques via la charge de la
dette
deuxièmement il y a un bac de stabilité
croissant gelé rappelé tout à l'heure
qui impose des règles et qui normalement
si les états respectent la loi ce pacte
de stabilité et à tueur mais doit les
conduire à se désendetter et c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait dans les années 2010
2020 ils se sont désendettés alors même
qu'ils pouvaient s'endetter à taux
négatifs c'est-à-dire gagner de l'argent
en empruntant donc cette solution a des
limites a des limites et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui les états rechignent
emprunté il ya une quatrième solution à
quatrième scénario qui est de de se dire
mettons enfin l'or c'est vrai que c'est
innovant c'est vrai que ça n'a jamais
été fait en tant que tel d'annuler les
têtes publique détenue par la banque
centrale mais la politique non
conventionnelle de la banque centrale en
2015 quand mario draghi l'a mis en place
ça non plus ça n'avait jamais été fait
alors on verra
bien compris nicolas réponse d'henri
sterdyniak
dans aucun pays dans aucun grand pays là
dès la banque centrale néo déficitaire
c'est une règle tout à fait simple dans
tous les pays où la banque centrale est
équilibré et la dette publique et tout
laisse porter par l'état ensuite on peut
fantasmer complètement
on peut fantasmer complètement et dire à
partir d'aujourd'hui
la dette publique va être porté par la
banque centrale et du coup ça va alléger
l'état mais dans la mesure où ça change
absolument pas la charge de la dette que
devront supporter l'ensemble banque
centrale plus état c'est complètement
complètement illusoire
donc le problème c'est que nous sommes
en face d'un illuminé qui propose des
solutions qui n'ont aucun sens qui n'ose
keith aucune somme y en a qui ne sont
pas mis en place dans des pays comme les
etats-unis ou le japon ou la grande
bretagne ou yahoo ya pas de pacte de
stabilité ou naturellement les boks en
clair la banque centrale pourrait le
faire c'est pas du tout la question la
question c'est bien sûr il faut
supprimer le pacte de stabilité et de
croissance
bien sûr bien sûr il faut que je pense à
des dépenses importantes pour la
transition écologique et ses dépenses
tout à fait naturellement
on va les financer par du crédit
bancaire
c'est pas un problème ensuite
contrairement à ce qu'a dit la personne
qui a parlé avec avant moi y'a aucun
rapport aucun rapport entre ma position
est celle du libéral de service
aujourd'hui ma position
ça consiste tout simplement à dire la
dette publique elle est désirée par des
agents il ya toujours des gens qui
veulent désir et de la dette publique
parce que la dette publique
c'est un actif sur la dette publique
française
c'est un actif sans risque donc il ya
des il ya de l'assurance vie
kieffer détenir il ya des pays étrangers
qui veulent en détenir donc à aucun
moment il n'y aura pas une génération
sacrifiée à qui on va dire rembourser la
dette publique
absolument pas la dette publique elle
tourne et dans 10 ans 20 ans on aura une
dette publique qui sera peut-être de
120% du peut-être 134,85 tout à
fait naturellement aucune génération ne
sera contraint de rembourser la dette
publique
la dette publique c'est un moyen de
rendre plus liquides la richesse et je
voudrais rappeler à ce monsieur qui ce
plat du sacrifice des deux du drame
d'été jeunes que la france n'est pas
endetté vis-à-vis de l'étranger donc que
la dette publique est détenue
comptablement par des français que
l'effet que les gens naturellement les
personnes plus ou moins âgées vont
décéder et qui vont léguer à leurs
enfants
d'un côté la dette publique mais aussi
les avoirs les assurances vie donc les
jeunes n'ont pas à s'affoler là dessus
un français qui naît à 250000 euros en
moyenne de richesse il vaut mieux naître
en france avec la dette qu'on a le temps
de nombreux autres pays et donc le
problème des jeunes c'est pas du tout la
dette publique
le problème des jeunes et je pense que
tout le monde sera d'accord là dessus
c'est la dette écologique c'est là le
grand problème d'intelligence ont
l'intelligence on oui un dernier mot
parce que l'émission se termine et vous
êtes en déficit de temps il reste deux
minutes mais je pense que pour cette
question encore une fois d'argent
magique
voilà ça me fait un peu penser à casa
del papel
où effectivement on voit la machine à
imprimer on se dit que c'est très facile
et qu'on peut le faire
l'argent il n'y a pas de côté magique
dans l'abonné est le distingue pas du
ciel bien évidemment on peut dire que ça
peut être une avance sur quelque chose
qui arrivera après mais voilà c'est de
toute façon c'est un impact sur
l'économie la monnaie a toujours eu un
impact sur l'économie depuis tous les
temps il ya des médias des monarques qui
ont effectivement essayé aussi de ne pas
rembourser ou d'avoir des moyens
détournés pour ne pas rembourser comme
lorsqu'il j'utilisais des deux du cuivre
plutôt que de l'or pour pouvoir diminuer
la valeur de la monnaie en réalité mais
ça finissait ça finissait souvent en
catastrophe
le problème de la dette publique c'est
de savoir ce qu'on en fait et voilà donc
s'il a des publics en plus non seulement
elle augmente mais elle n'est pas
productive et bien ça devient un
problème donc donc voilà donc pour le
moment qu après on est décidés à voir
une dette publique parce
qu'effectivement on est face à une
situation inédite où l'état du a ordonné
à des entreprises d'arrêter son activité
et bien cette dette elle est très liée à
un contexte si ce contexte s'améliore il
n'y a pas de raison pour que l'état ne
puisse pas rembourser
et après on peut avoir envie de financer
de la finance verte c'est un autre débat
c'est un débat sur la façon dont on
alloue le budget de l'état et là on
consacre ne l'est pas on décide de
constater des part importante du budget
d'état maison en aucun cas ça on
obtiendra quelque chose de mieux avec
avec un côté il n'ya pas de côté magique
à l'amener sagana diaries le reste 40
secondes 30
oui alors pour répondre très vite à
monsieur dufresne bon ce dernier avait
bien dit on n'est pas d'accord sur les
solutions n'a pas du tout les mêmes
solutions en revanche on est d'accord
sur un constat c'est qu'il ya toujours
ya pas d'argent magique et toujours
quelqu'un qui paie donc quand vous dites
monnaies libres sans création d'êtres
contrepartiste vous proposer ces appels
l'inflation la planche à billets et donc
la dilution du pouvoir d'achat de la
monnaie
ce qui implique que qui est toujours eca
qui perd ce quelqu'un ça peut peut-être
l'épargnant leur entier mais votre
solution qui consiste à feindre que tout
sera gratuit que personne ne paiera
je crois et est un peut être un peu
démago maintenant effectivement ce qui
me concerne je pense que il faut
rappeler qu'il ya toujours quelqu'un qui
paie et que se pose la question du
moindre mal et de celui qui est légitime
ou non à payer cette dette qui a été
généré par nos aînés moi je maintiens
que faire payer cette dette sur les
travailleurs et l'impôt ça reste injuste
et que l'urgence est au retour des
libertés économiques pour faire revenir
la croissance mais qu'est-ce que se
posera la question aussi de la juste
répartition du poids de cette dette qui
ne peut pas à mon avis incomber aux
générations futures
merci tous les quatre d'avoir participé
à cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis
rendez vous au prochain numéro et
probablement on en reparlera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]